Traduttore: Marianna Gusmeroli
Revisore: Sabrina Mori
Avete di fronte a voi
un prodotto in via di estinzione.
Io ho 54 anni, mi chiamo Paolo Bonolis,
sono 35 anni che lavoro nell'ideazione,
nella scrittura e nella conduzione
di programmi televisivi.
Io non ho scoperte da mostrarvi.
Non ho una conoscenza così profonda
da poter condividere con voi,
o da potervi insegnare.
E giustamente voi vi farete la domanda:
"allora che vuoi?"
Sono qui perché m'hanno invitato
e io cinque anni fa, sei anni fa circa,
conobbi per la prima volta,
grazie a uno degli autori
che lavora con me,
il mondo di Ted e l'ho trovato bellissimo,
l'ho trovata una delle cose più belle
che ho visto negli ultimi vent'anni.
È uno splendido osservatorio,
un osservatorio della conoscenza
e della condivisione.
Quando mi hanno chiesto
di partecipare
allora ho detto
"va bene, partecipo".
Però mi sono anche domandato:
"mo' che dico a questi?"
Giustamente, non avendo scoperte
e non avendo conoscenze
provo a condividere con voi un pensiero,
un pensiero che mi è venuto in mente
quando mi hanno chiesto di venire qui.
E il pensiero mi è venuto in mente
ricordando quando, da ragazzo,
e ancora oggi, leggevo
libri di fantascienza.
Ne ho letti tantissimi, tantissimi.
E alcuni racconti di fantascienza
mi hanno colpito più di altri,
tanto che, questo che vi sto
brevemente per raccontare,
mi è rimasto impresso dopo quasi
quarant'anni che l'avevo letto.
È un libro scritto da -
io non sono analogico -
scritto da un certo Fredric.
È un racconto breve, del 1954.
ed è un racconto che racconta
una storia buffa, strana,
piccola, piccola, piccola.
Un gruppo di scienziati,
in quell'anno del 1954,
decide di costruire un computer.
I computer - se avete visto il film
"The Imitation Game" potete capirlo -
i computer allora erano
dei giganteschi monoliti,
una sorta di vergine di Norimberga,
dove, invece che degli spuntoni
dentro c'erano transistor, valvole,
queste cose qua.
Costruiscono questo coso gigantesco
al quale pongono la domanda
delle domande:
Dio esiste?
Dopo pochi secondi
(suono sibilante)
esce la risposta:
"potenza di calcolo insufficiente".
"Eh, cavoli, giusto"
dicono gli scienziati.
"La domanda è così enorme..."
Allora costruiscono
un altro computer,
altrettanto grande,
e - stiamo parlando
di un romanzo del 1954 -
connettono questi due computer
per rendere più potente la potenza,
giustappunto, della ricerca.
Fondamentalmente, nel 1954,
questo tal Fredric
aveva costruito nella sua immaginazione
la prima maglia di quella che
sarebbe stata poi la rete.
Alla domanda: "Dio esiste?"
la risposta è sempre la stessa.
"Potenza di calcolo insufficiente".
Questo manipolo di scienziati
decidono di non darsi per vinto
e continuano a costruire computer
e a connettere un computer all'altro
creando una sorta di cittadina
di computer giganteschi,
connessi tra di loro.
Ma alla domanda: "Dio esiste?"
la risposta è sempre la stessa.
"Potenza di calcolo insufficiente".
Passano i decenni,
passano i secoli.
La tecnologia cresce,
cresce in maniera smisurata,
al punto che i computer ormai
sono sofisticatissimi,
talmente sofisticati,
talmente connessi tra loro
che riescono ad autorigenerarsi.
Ma alla domanda preimpostata
"Dio esiste?"
la risposta è sempre la stessa.
"Potenza di calcolo insufficiente".
Questa storia va un po' per le lunghe.
L'umanità scompare.
Non c'è più nessuno.
C'è solamente questo
infinito esercito di computer
che continua a riprodursi,
diventando gigantesco.
Finché un giorno,
nel silenzio dell'universo,
Alla domanda preimpostata: "Dio esiste?"
esce la risposta.
"Adesso sì".
Il racconto breve s'intitola "The Answer",
ed è scritto da questo tal Fredric
di cui non ricordo il cognome.
Ma perché vi ho fatto questo racconto?
Perché mi è venuto in mente ?
Perché secondo me
c'è una analogia già nascosta nel racconto
e provo a condividere un mio pensiero
- potete ricusarlo, potete fischiarlo,
potete rifiutarlo completamente.
Però mi è venuto in mente così.
Io non ho, come lo chiamano gli americani,
(finte parole inglesi)
quel coso lì che se fa così.
Sono analogico, ma funziona
e te lo puoi portare dappertutto.
(Schiocca le dita)
(Risate)
(Applausi)
L'analogia è tra Dio e il computer.
Dio - qualunque dio vogliate voi,
mettetela come volete.
Però effettivamente perché,
fin dagli albori dell'umanità
l'uomo ha confezionato l'idea
e la proiezione di Dio?
E perché oggi c'è questa
pulsione fortissima
nei confronti della rete, del computer,
della tecnologia che permette ciò?
Perché secondo me
sia Dio che il computer
ci danno una opportunità.
Quella di scavallare le colonne d'Ercole
della nostra esistenza terrena,
ciò che ci tiene qui,
bloccati e un po' afflitti.
Lo spazio e il tempo.
Grazie alla velocità del computer,
e alle sue possibilità,
noi ci possiamo muovere
velocemente tra spazio e tempo
nel mondo virtuale.
Certo, per Dio bisogna aspettare un po'.
Bisogna aspettare di tirare le cuoia,
siamo in una vita ultraterrena.
Ma, bene o male, la zuppa è la stessa.
Fondamentalmente noi,
attraverso la figura di Dio,
e la figura del computer,
Cerchiamo di vincere questa
eterna battaglia della nostra vita,
superare queste barriere,
lo spazio e il tempo.
Ed è un processo logico,
voler affrontare la problematica.
Però,
la storia è un processo di apprendimento
quanto un processo di dimenticanze.
Allora io, che non sono un digitale -
sono un analogico -
vi offro una riflessione.
Occhio alla penna.
Non so come tradurranno,
se poi questa cosa andrà a tutto il mondo.
Attenzione, perché il computer,
la velocità, la virtualità,
può creare degli smarrimenti.
Quali sono questi smarrimenti?
Alcuni sono abbastanza evidenti.
L'atrofizzazione, ad esempio,
della memoria.
Noi deleghiamo tutto a qualcuno
che si ricorda tutto per noi,
e poi noi ci dimentichiamo
tutto quello che invece potremmo
ricordare con la nostra mente,
tenendola allenata.
E questo è un punto uno.
La conoscenza -
prima ho sentito la chiacchierata
del nostro amico greco -
la conoscenza, sì, è importante,
ma la conoscenza attraverso la rete
è una conoscenza indotta.
Non è una conoscenza dedotta.
È una conoscenza un po' differente,
dove si vengono ad abbattere
i nostri cinque sensi,
la possibilità di conoscere
buttandoci addosso l'esperienza
del raggiungere l'obiettivo.
E questo ci porta al terzo punto,
da dividere in due maniere.
Una è il disagio.
Qual è il disagio che potrebbero avvertire
i nativi digitali?
Il disagio di poter vivere la virtualità
in assenza di spazio e di tempo
- o quantomeno talmente limitato
da apparire assente -
e ritrovarsi poi nella realtà dove
spazio e tempo sono belli pesanti,
da affrontare.
Se li accetti, ci vivi.
Se li dimentichi, diventano
dei bastioni insormontabili,
che renderebbero probabilmente
la nostra vita piuttosto disagiata.
Ma lo stesso tipo di disagio
lo si può rintracciare in un altro modo.
È sotterraneo, è subcutaneo.
È la perdita del valore.
Perché cosa conferisce valore ad una cosa?
La fatica di poterla raggiungere.
La fatica impiegata per ottenerla.
Nello spazio, noi facciamo fatica
a raggiungere un posto,
attraverso tale fatica raccogliamo
un mare di informazioni,
le facciamo nostre, e quando questo posto
finalmente viene raggiunto...
caspita, se ce lo ricordiamo.
Perché è tutta la fatica investita
che ce lo rende prezioso.
E nel tempo? Nel tempo è la stessa cosa.
Sarebbe un problema
smarrire il senso dell'attesa.
La velocità repentina
di poter ottenere una cosa
ci toglie l'attesa.
In assenza di attesa
il desiderato, una volta ottenuto,
non ha quel valore
che altrimenti avrebbe avuto
se lo avessimo dovuto aspettare.
Insomma, può sembrare il minimo sindacale,
quello che mi è venuto in mente
da potervi raccontare qui.
Ve lo ho detto e sono stato felice
di poterlo condividere.
Poi trattate voi l'argomento
come riterrete più opportuno.
Ve lo ho detto, tra me e voi
c'è quello che viene chiamato
"Digital divide".
Io sono analogico, voi siete digitali.
Vi ho parlato come se fossi un padre,
sono il più vecchio, credo,
tra chi ha parlato.
Ho cinquantaquattro anni, dico.
Però sono contento di averlo fatto,
anche se -
un po' mi sento sconfitto,
in questo pensiero,
perché mirabilmente un grande sociologo,
Guy Debord, ha detto:
(schiocca le dita)
"L'uomo assomiglia ai suoi tempi
più di quanto assomigli a suo padre".
Grazie.
(Applausi)